- So I thought it, I
thought it might be fun
since you love sun glasses,
you're known for it.
I thought it might be fun to try on, like,
a few iconic frames, see
how they look on you.
Are you cool with that?
- I'm with it.
- All right, all right.
C'mon out here elf!
(jaunty Christmas music)
(crowd cheering)
He's like the most miserable elf!
(groaning and laughing)
It's great, great.
(crowd laughing)
He is killin' that Christmas spirit!
All right, all right, let's
ease into it, shall we?
Okay, I think we're gonna
go with these first.
These are like, they kinda
look like U2, like Bono,
a little Bono-esque.
So, let's try these.
- Make some noise for Bono!
- Exactly!
(crowd cheering)
I love Bono!
Let's see, yeah!
(crowd cheering)
- Those are good on you.
- Yes, they do look good on you!
Okay, okay!
Well, this one, this is uh, I think Oprah
has been rocking a bold
look like these, these days.
So, I mean, if it's good for Oprah,
it's good for all of us, right?
This is probably
on her Favorite things!
- Make some noise for Oprah!
- Oprah!
(crowd cheering)
- Yep!
- You look good in sun glasses,
you have like the perfect
shape head, I'm not kidding, I look,
I have to go for a specific
style or it's like, nope!
Okay, we're gonna go for these,
obviously these are a little
Elton John, make some
noise for Elton John!
(crowd cheering)
These are a little more Elton John,
these are, these are a little flashy.
Little flashy, yep.
(laughing)
(crowd and Kelly cheer and applaud)
Yeah!
You look good!
- Y'all got me good,
y'all got me good on this,
y'all got me.
- Which one is your
favorite, if you had to pick?
'Cause I'm just sayin'
the bedazzle is nice!
- Uh, I may go with these.
- Oh you're goin' the Oprah, I see.
- Yeah, I may go the
Oprah, I may go with Oprah.
- You can't go wrong.
(crowd cheering)
You can't go wrong.
You gonna rock those for
the rest of the show?
You don't have to, yours
are pretty cool too.